hey what's up everybody welcome to the
are you garbage comedy podcast please
take a second to subscribe to the
YouTube channel that way you get the
episodes as they come out thanks a lot
welcome to another exciting edition of
ru garbage the show where you find out
if your favorite comedians are classy
individuals or absolute trash now here
are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is ru garbage where we sit down with
your favorite comedians and find out if
they grew up classy or if they grew up
trash I'm your host H Foley coming at
you on a beautiful day here in a story
of Queens New York City my partner on
the other hand ran for the hills at the
first sign of the Roma he's at an
undisclosed location somewhere in
southern Pennsylvania give it up for my
good pal hippy Kevin James Ryan
everybody what's up guys I feel I've
been shy changed Bunker's again I feel
like [ __ ] Saddam in his last few days
man sleeping in the same place choice
fun are you from a spider hole [ __ ] that
happy to be here guys thanks so much for
tuning in we appreciate it make sure you
rate review subscribe you know on iTunes
Spotify YouTube all that full videos up
on YouTube we appreciate all the support
so far thanks guys
very nice we have a very special guest
today one of my absolute favorites I
know want to get these favorites
he's an absolute get I'm gonna read this
rap sheet off to you real quick Kip er
it's gonna take a couple of minutes
because the man has got some [ __ ]
credits we'll kick it off with Last
Comic Standing
comedy central half hour got some comedy
live Ben on the bonfire has his own
special on Comedy Central it's been on
inside Amy Schumer roast battle The Late
Show with Stephen Colbert okay
The Late Show with James Corden this
week at the Comedy Cellar appeared on
the Conan O'Brien show seven [ __ ]
times been on The Tonight Show three
times Joe Rogan he's the co-host of
Tuesday's of stories he's also been on
horace and beat the acclaimed show and
not that he shows it off like these
other thoughts on instagram but he's got
a tight little body on them coming out
here from the West Village in Manhattan
ladies and gentlemen mr. mark [ __ ]
Norman everybody hey buddy look at you
kids got a motor on them Jesus nice
[ __ ] homeowner twos guys own place
come in the Ville I just want my parents
love my dad's a [ __ ] I can't get a Hello
a text a pat on the back so I don't know
I'm I'm striving for something here is
that true well you're putting your
parents do by the way I get to find I
know you're from New Orleans
are they there to learn ed people right
don't they do something intellectual
queefs they out there always get their
head in a book and that on their son
they're nice people my dad's real estate
douche and my mom runs a museum so
they're kind of uppity that's a real
estate guy in New Orleans yeah and you
and we've talked about this before but
you grew up in the house that they
filmed Miller's Crossing right the one
that Leo the Lion ode that's right
that's right yeah they lit it on fire
and they had to like blow the light your
hands alone he jumps out a window in an
Alfa balcony and I remember the whole
thing I saw the shoot the Coen brothers
it was wild I was a wee lad so give me I
don't know if you've seen this place
it's a nice [ __ ] house you know I
mean it's it's it's a nice house in the
wounds so I mean he's got wounded
parents he's an accomplished man but the
question is is he [ __ ] garbage well
give my mace sure of course the house
was not nice when I lived there and my
dad is the most edward rich guy on the
night we have money maybe in a beaver
with drip seats no engine wait Alexa
with with bloodstains in it lady there's
no stopping a police auction what the
[ __ ] he was an auction guy oh that's no
[ __ ] good if you're an auction guy
that's bad news
every piece of furniture had a
menstruation stand on it it all here in
the fabric hornet's nest in the back it
was brutal
throwing the dead baby for free I know
that I always I always wanted to go to
one of those police auctions it would
like show it on the TV or whatever we
drive by it on the highway my dad was
like no [ __ ] away are we going to
that thing
I would love to do you get a cheap gun
or uh ski mask I know a couple of pit
bulls yeah the other stuff that's the it
sounded great to a teenager that's like
all you ever wanted of court beer that
cracker jack thing you hit people with a
little metal thing all right yeah yeah
yeah they use those in the 20s the black
jack that's a tough guy always pulled
that out and went over the head with it
I know that we always clean that was
always scarier than a gun like in the
movies if somebody had that baby they
really didn't [ __ ] mess around that
would major brain damage oh yeah did you
guys have the we all every high school
had the one kid with the old cop car did
you guys have that yeah yeah we had one
of those do yeah that was kind of me I
had a I had an old big body white Chevy
lumina so it was very common was very
undercover cop car esque yeah my friend
Doug had an old cop car and still had a
couple the decals on it because he
couldn't get them all off and every time
we rolled up to a party boo and run it
was always a great entrance that's like
out of a high school movie dude that's
[ __ ] awesome
did it have a spotlight on it cuz that's
a real [ __ ] trash people that had
splinter it didn't work but it was that
metal big metal bulbous thing on the
side yeah that's [ __ ] garbage yeah
and also - so tell us about growing up
in New Orleans were you in the suburbs
or were you in the city proper city kid
through and through I grew up in Treme
right outside of the French Quarter like
my neighborhood now has changed because
of gentrification and Katrina kind of
gave a big enema to the whole city but
when I was a kid it was
terrifying Amer we did a beating my
friend at a lemonade stand
we must have been six seven years old
did a lemonade stand bunch of kids is
trash in front of them
they just broke the whole thing down
they do the lemonade on the ground they
junk it they smashed the picture it was
Wayans black kids what are we talking
about here yeah yeah it was a black
neighborhood was a poor black
neighborhood and we were the white
family in a mansion Jesus so that that
house you're talking about was in the
house and Miller's Crossing was in that
neighborhood yes yeah it's an old
historic neighborhood we were we were
sitting tucks it was brutal we got
robbed costly and I thought we were rich
we'll be worked so the truck is on oh
yeah that's an interesting situation I
[ __ ] love that and then you guys have
Tuesday's of stories don't you have
didn't you guys run like a boarding
house or something like that
yeah Wow you know your homework we we
made the back half of it it was so big
we literally had a back wing and we made
that a bed and breakfast because we need
a more income just fixing up the house
was way more than my parents can afford
so they said [ __ ] it let's just used
this space we got there you go this is
like the beginning of a bad novel
that's why it was a bad novel all right
Huckleberry Finn would you say how much
would you say even a good childhood
growing up yeah yeah it was okay I mean
it was terrifying and I'm crazy anxiety
like our alarm would go off at 4:00 in
the morning and you just knew a guy was
downstairs
it was just easiest it was just that
weird and you know I can't relax and I
remember the first week I moved in this
kid knocks on the door he's about the
same age as me so I'm like hey a new
friend here we go how old do you have a
Nintendo I go I do damn right I do it on
here get your ass in here
Tyrone's I can play some duck on baby
Riley jammers in the fridge and he goes
what games you got and I had some
top-of-the-line you know Excitebike and
contra and some big ones so good he goes
oh well we should trade he had Tetris
like Zelda a bunch of boring [ __ ] okay I
never saw him again
give us 38 years old it's a grown man
showing up on your porch
yeah exactly I bought it hook line and
sinker never saw the kid again he got
all the good games Jesus what's New
Orleans is a bit of a day I was there
not too long girl and maybe like two
years ago for a bachelor party that is a
date for the first time that is a dicey
[ __ ] City man that's like you got to
keep your head on a swivel even still I
was just like I feel like there's just
like vagrants and weird people like real
[ __ ] trashy people walking around
that place it's it's terrifying and that
was that was 90s and I was late 80s
Early 90s so it was weird no cameras no
cell phones so like it was a Wild West
it was a scary place I came in New York
and everybody's like watch out it's the
big city this was nothing compared to
the big yeah I felt that same way from
Philly and it's like Philly's a tougher
New York's like all pussified now
there's I don't I feel safe walking in
any neighborhood in Manhattan you know
some a Brooklyn are still dicey
obviously bright right
I hope the Phillies by block it's like
you can like you can make a wrong turn
in Center City and be like why are the
[ __ ] am i 100% yeah and at least New
York there's always a guy walking around
or there's a lady's a family walk around
in Philly or New Orleans like it's gonna
black dark double yeah for sure yeah you
get into a lot of fights as a kid like
did you have to fight a lot down there
got beat up what a way to put that what
a way to answer that there you go
even if you win then the friends were
jumpy like you couldn't do it's not a
real win-win situation Jesus
damn you're like Kevin Bacon and
Footloose or something like that that
was you had you had it you had a squad
though right you had like a crew of
friends no life friends lived in the
burbs and they would come in like this
how big my house was first of all my
brother is like a computer genius
because he never left his bedroom
because he was too scared so he just
learned how to do it like Doss and all
that [ __ ] and my friends would come over
and my house is so big we would
skateboard in that parlor of the house
like in the front room we built a little
skate park in there we made escape a
ramp in the backyard
it was just so scary going out there
that like we did everything in the house
dude who is your [ __ ] dad this yeah
that's an insane decision to put someone
to put your family through and where are
they from where are your parents from
that they decided to move in to this
house in Treme in the Orleans Life my
tree my dad's from this little town
called Marksville it's like a little
just dirt road town in Louisiana in the
backwoods and he grew up dirt poor and
he had a weird bad childhood I don't get
into it
so I think he was like I'm making
something myself I'm moving to New
Orleans I'm buying this mansion
everybody's gonna love me I'm gonna be a
hero and he loves old [ __ ] he's like
he's part of the Preservation Society so
he's like I'm gonna be the dude who
fixes this [ __ ] door he's the guy who
owns mansion yeah Jesus whoo that's a
[ __ ] treatment right that's like
Goonies or something
I've been try to sell this thing for 10
years but everybody's such a queef they
won't buy it
oh that's [ __ ] insane man sure been
gay yeah there you go
I know do you do you think you're
garbage that's what I want to know do
you think I mean by the looks of you
you're very well put together you got
good style you know what I mean you're
doing all right for yourself don't good
definitely there's there's some stories
floating around the [ __ ] you know the
New York comedy scene that like don't
paint not like in a bad way but like the
usual like taking chicken wings off
people's plates like recently act like
there's one story that says that it's
apparently you acted like a waiter and
we're eating chicken wings and then on
stage
yes that's right well first of all we
had no food in my house because my
parents were so busy working so I see
free food I have to eat it like I've
gone into hotels there's a double tree
in the in Midtown you get the free
cookie I'll just go in and pretend like
I'll stay in there don't blame at going
I got a plaid shirt on you're like
George's episode yeah I'll give you that
there's two kinds of people there's
people that will eat off other people's
plates and people that want that I
whereas I worked as a waiter for so long
I'd be so [ __ ] hungry that it's like
if it I used the rule that if it was
like an older person or a good-looking
girl I would always eat whatever they
whatever they didn't finish to a degree
like if they left a couple of scallops
on the plate I'm gonna eat it I'm not
gonna finish there am burger yes right
into some of their soup girls but I can
eat [ __ ] one of her [ __ ] chicken
wings exactly and the individual is like
a chicken nugget a chicken wing a piece
of shrimp all that is is game something
that hasn't been touched or manhandled
for sure I mean you're still rolling the
dice now obviously with the corona we
realize it's [ __ ] everywhere you're
fine I mean think about humans evolved
we had eat [ __ ] off the floor into eat
berries and poison and Rhett rats
[ __ ] we're fine we're built for this
[ __ ] all right let's give in to some
questions here Kippy you want to start
it off you can start off buddy all right
a couple of things here we'll just go
over mark we're gonna ask you a series
of questions to determine whether where
you line up on the trash meter or not
the last thing I wanted to know is
growing up anywhere in your house was
there a Garfield a hamburger or a
football phone I always wanted one I
always wanted that hamburger phone -
chicken nugget elephant big painters
over here right always 101 but my
parents they wouldn't they wouldn't that
was too fun like that was that's they're
not they're cheap they're frugal they're
gonna buy a goddamn like something a pan
or a frying pan or something something
in used they would never buy that I
guess I could have bought it with my own
money but I'd have any money that was
too fun for the house okay so there was
no subscription to Sports Illustrated in
the house oh there's no Rivlin spending
see that's good though cuz that would be
if you would have had that stuff that
would you would be garbage okay okay but
I'm not garbage because they were cheap
yeah swell I mean you're for that
question yeah I think you end up might
be garbage though but we'll see um do
you guys ever run a chia pet we'd have a
chia pet but we had a big mouth bass no
that was my next [ __ ] question
no way dude yeah Jesus a big mouth Billy
bass that's uninsured where was it it
was it was just in a pile it was even on
the wall didn't it make on the walls a
file like of [ __ ] you know like you have
a drunk junk drawer or something it was
in a drawer like that geez any uh have
you ever had your palm read or is any
member of your family a psychic
oh no no I'm in a weird corner here
because my parents are intellectual
pretentious [ __ ] but like they wouldn't
believe all that they're like we're not
going to church that's gonna require
using the car we don't believe in
anything yeah so they're smart but
they're still gross that makes sense
yeah no no no palm reader that would be
too silly that's too dumb and you know
it's like saying as a ghost in the house
yeah yeah I'm growing up did you have a
discman yes and then did that discman
have anti skip protection yes buddy an
anti skip protection in the 90s was
cleaned [ __ ] living or a [ __ ] rich
kid I was like holy [ __ ] I had a I had a
broken CD player with the the top was
gone oh it would just spin Wow
what about a dude growing up did you
ever eat a removable shower head could
you take it off the wall and like do the
back and stuff like that had a little
hose on it no no we moved eventually
because we got robbed so much in the new
house had it but it just came with the
house but this one did not okay remember
this is old plumbing here this is old
[ __ ] we're dealing with this is like a
teen whatever plumbing all right have
you or any family member taken a couch
or other piece of furniture from someone
else's trash yes yes Mike
was a trash couch geez the cows won in
her apartment right now no my bedroom it
was a mansion so my bed was huge it had
a couch in it and it was a trash couch
that's tough but as a kid that's like if
you has a kid you always look for that
[ __ ]
like I can [ __ ] baby I dude I skated
too so I was always like I can make a
ramp out of that or a box or a something
you know what I mean it was just
constantly taking [ __ ] to try to make
something when I totally totally when I
lived in New York the first time before
I did a comedy I lived in in Sunnyside
and I did that I took a chair off the
street and then like two months later
people were complaining about bedbugs
and then I noticed bedbugs in my
apartment and like I started [ __ ]
going out to the landlord I'm not paying
one day I looked underneath this chair I
was cleaning my whole apartment trying
to get rid of the bedbugs and there's
just a huge [ __ ] bedbug nests under
that chair I was the one that brought
him and got the whole building Zack
[ __ ] patient zero over there Jesus
grace did you come clean did you admit
it do that I would have been liable for
like [ __ ] the entire building I
rolled I [ __ ] didn't pay the last
month rent rolled out it yeah blame it
on the weird European guy down the hall
he said I was going to rehab or
something like that
did I bedbugs in Bushwick there's
nothing worse I've had everything
bedbugs is the worst thing you look like
a knob and that's like that you telling
somebody in New York that you have
bedbugs is literally is like saying just
worse than it like nobody dude I would
look at anybody differently if you got
bedbugs for surely you have to throw out
every single thing you own everything in
the apartment has to go in order to
somewhat feel safe and secure
yeah I had to move nothing worked I
tried an exterminator I try to seance
everything doesn't work
Jesus Christ that's [ __ ] brutal all
right I got one now I know Kevin does
this and I think this is absolute [ __ ]
garbage
mr. Norman did you and your family open
Christmas presents on Christmas Eve we
got one we got one on Christmas Eve
one's respectable but you know but the
rest of them aren't Christmas morning
right
yeah Kevin would you guys do over at the
riot house no all right I didn't feel
like I have to defend myself December
23rd you're opening we needed we needed
a pawn it to pay rent no we we do with
that now because we're older and it's
what everybody has their own things
going on but as a kid I wasn't like a
[ __ ] five-year-old you know digging
through wrapping paper at midnight
I thought you guys did it on Christmas
Eve because your father had to work uh
no later on yeah cuz she worked in a
hospital
he's a hero okay jerk-off and trigger
with some [ __ ] respect
go ahead Kippy what do you got as a kid
did you ever growing up did you wear
aqua socks or water shoes oh yeah man
was a [ __ ] mark at the pool that was
where were you swimming as a kid we have
big puddles ha no ice you eat some
big-ass puddles in the neighborhood so
you throw the aqua sock on it yeah you
run around in it what about my swimming
where would you go you guys never pool
at the mansion did you know we didn't
swim we you didn't swim you just
hopefully got to the beach once that
year or your friend had a pool or
something but it was no swimming unless
you were in a hotel I figured if you're
on the water aren't you aren't you on
the water wouldn't you jump into the
golfer and something like that
that [ __ ] is pure poison I mean we just
had an oil spill in there the oil
cleaned it up
it's gross there's Crocs and Gators and
yeah that's like swampland your swamp
yeah yeah you don't want any harsh yeah
yeah it's like going in the [ __ ] East
River what are you doing exactly yeah
okay um okay I took about my dad I
called my buddy ran into my dad at the
mall like I don't know eight years ago
and he texted music dude I'm at the mall
and your dad's wearing aqua Sox my dad
is such a [ __ ] dork he wore aqua Sox
in Publix of the [ __ ] mall oh Jesus
Christ man what are we doing here my dad
we're a full bathrobe no everywhere
around the house around the house
hey dude dad plays by his own [ __ ]
rules and I like oh no doubt about it
if you were lucky he was wearing no
underwear in a skate shirt so he'd have
a shirt it's it like
bird house no underwear in a robe yes oh
my god and that what did you ever try to
like be like hey you know put some
[ __ ] DVDs on I got people coming over
no you just got used to it you know
you're just like ah dad's crossing his
legs look towards the Sun oh my god
that's fair dad yeah we gotta get your
dad on here oh [ __ ]
never have a lava lamp I wanted one bad
never had one man I really wanted one
yeah what about a beanbag chair everyone
a beanbag I had that to all my friends
and the burbs had a beanbag I never had
one again the beanbag was too fun it was
like no one would ever have gotten by
that it was not a necessity all right I
got one that might be more your speed
have you ever played in a car that
didn't run of course
Gordon oh that's tough they run a trash
plane family in the car I've done that
before all it was like a joke if you go
to the sunroof you go yeah I'm a couple
of times you like rip that's in the
backseat down you could get into the
trunk and then you're like hiding in the
trunk that was it right I was [ __ ]
tree trunk at a wasp nests in of roots
your first year those things were a
pissed-off [ __ ] Hospital I don't know
why they were always way more aggressive
than regular bees and [ __ ] that's true
all right as like a teenager did you
ever dye your hair or frost your tips oh
well my brother was Goths
Oh God a goth computer programmer that's
it that's a turn I mean he had black
[ __ ] on the windows he had a butt cut it
was the 90s he had the book I had one
once I was dyed white and the other side
was black Wow
there was probably some parents or
teachers afraid of that kid for sure
he's older than me so his pre Columbine
but he was he was knocking on that door
can you chill out with theirs you still
walk around busting out look the kids
and that's too funny was your parents
bedroom downstairs was the master
bedroom of the house downstairs no
downstairs was too scary you would get
killed to be lived down there you had to
be up and high in the tree house in the
furture I always thought that was
garbage when he'd go to your friend's
house for some reason like from like an
addition that they put on the house or
just the way the house was laid out that
their parents bedroom was on the first
floor what the [ __ ]
that was weird oh one more thing with
the haircut let me just say this oh I
went to public school it was one of the
few white kids so my dad used to cut my
hair that's that's that's we've asked
that before on this that is a dead trash
move right there I did it yeah big trash
move but one day at the phone rang so he
walked to get the phone I grabbed the
Clippers I wanted to fit in with the
kids so I shaved lines in my side here
boy did I get my ass kicked by your dad
and the kids in school the kids in
school and my dad every time every time
we go somewhere though I look at his
shoes he's like [ __ ] on him like a
black teen through my mom my mom used to
cut my hair like as we were kids in the
summer and I wanted it I wanted to be
same thing I wanted to be cool you know
I wanted some sort of design so she did
she put a number one in the back of my
head man that did not that did not look
good or was received well in the in the
clinic oldest act no sir no sir and I
walked into school in this black it goes
oh he trapped me bad auntie that's
heart-wrenching you didn't play any
sports or anything time high school did
you know no I wanted to get in and out
but I skateboarded we skateboard all day
every day all day on the weekends
nothing organized I did karate as a kid
but that didn't last that worked out for
you not good
still got a cell doesn't hold up in the
street I can tell you that yeah I'm
scared of people that know like jujitsu
and stuff like that but if someone's
like I know karate come on go back to
school will ya um all right I got one
that was always my family didn't do it
but when I remember going over my
buddy's house and seeing it did your
parents keep the batteries in the
refrigerator Oh bad move man you trying
to get that every little ounce you can
out of this um we going though we kept
ours in the freezer
pekes spend a couple of bucks
go pump a new set of door ourselves what
are we doing that's a myth by the way I
don't think give that a goob that ain't
real oh it doesn't work no that's a myth
just an old wives tale here's what they
I'm not gonna get to this I don't wanna
jump here you know by all means please
my mom was obsessed with garage sales
obsessed like on Saturday our big outing
wish you would circle them all the ones
near us in the newspaper and we'd go to
every one it took like eight hours what
was she looking for anything specific or
just household items you can use any
would help out around the house maybe a
gift or uh you know a [ __ ] piece of
jewelry and then she was a coupon skank
big coupon oh man yeah that's coupons I
get cuz it's like there's a mother's a
value to it there's a monetary you know
an immediate monetary value to it but
mom's you said not [ __ ] around with
those my mom would hold the girl to the
coals if they said to all this one's not
valid what do you thought she would
[ __ ] lose it yes yes and you got a
line three feet deep behind the
winn-dixie everybody hates you okay wait
was that the name of your grocery store
the winn-dixie yeah that is some
southern [ __ ] right there
that was the grocery store in swing
blade I think it was right next to the
Double Deuce
that's for John Ritter worth
haha John Ritter was great and
Slingblade by the way uh yeah alright be
did you ever own a snake or a lizard no
no again too fun we got a dog with a dog
named shadow and it died by playing in a
dance dance drive vile I want to n PI oh
Jesus like killing what do you mean when
the Empire swarmed it he died your
childhood is insane dude this is like a
Coen Brothers movie this is [ __ ] wait
a minute what were they fire ants I
guess but he was playing that pile they
all swarmed him and they just bit him
all at once and he big bit so many times
he died went into shock or something
yeah you hear about that did you way out
no I started the carcass and it was bear
baby it was rough but yeah I didn't see
the actual death give her own a CB radio
all my friends at radar I had a CB that
didn't work you know what's really
trashy you might my stepdad had one of
those in this pickup truck too but it
was really trashy as a police scanner if
you got a [ __ ] police we had that man
my grand my grandfather my dad would sit
there and listen to the police scanner
to find out what's going on like they
were [ __ ] Batman and Robin I love a
trashy I don't know that's good stuff
yeah you guys do the citizen app no
what's that oh dude
get it on your iphone it tells you all
the crime in New York I don't know if I
want to know that is there anything
skidded that
yeah freaked you out a little bit or no
terrifying me and Miguel you like
sitting on our couch but hey to blocks
away so right about that sucks for them
jeez that's crazy yeah no I don't know
if I want that information all the time
yeah it's the new police scanner
basically did your mom have a
clothesline where she hung clothes on no
no no she did that right on the back of
a chair
whooshing college with the [ __ ] right
next to the mini-fridge yeah okay have
you ever used the chili-cheese machine
at a 7-eleven
no again we did we had bodega they
didn't have that [ __ ]
we had like shitty corner store with the
Korean guy and everything was behind
glass bulletproof you had to spin that
little lazy susan to get your Snickers
bar kind of yeah
there was no cheese machine there was no
IC machine there was no fun no nothing
self-serve Jesus
[ __ ] hell House Rules yeah I picture
you growing up like you know
all-american kids suburbs [ __ ] Bart
Simpson skateboard and Slurpee in your
hand skittles it's more like Eminem for
me [ __ ] what's okay said it's more like
Eminem from 8 mile yeah yeah brutal okay
got another have you ever worn pants
that zip into shorts nope as a teenager
yeah because you skateboard and you get
hot oh man they they came out they
thought they were the coolest they were
they see they were cool for like an hour
and a half but then they fell off real
quick mine were cargo yeah dude this is
how it my stepdad when they went to
Jamaica he was on the plane where and
then the plan before the plane the plane
landed he went to the bedroom and came
back in shorts and my mom was like what
dose is this get ready for the Butte
yeah what are you talking about this is
ready to party ripped his sleeves off
ready to go hang ten right I'm scared
no it's it's cool now cuz I see parents
doing it now it's very acceptable and
like the whole family will dress alike
but when we were kids it was always
weird
did your parents when you went
trick-or-treating ever dress up for
Halloween oh no I wish I wish that would
be cool I always thought that was weird
or like he'd see like somebody's dad in
the 80s in the early 90s we're in like
an off-brand Superman costume like what
the [ __ ] is this guy doing
yeah that is a little that's a little
weird I guess but
something kind of cool about your dad
dressing up as Batman at your Robin yeah
that's pretty cool pretty cool my god I
feel bad for Dortmund well I mean if my
dad dressed up I know he gave a [ __ ]
that'd be nice CSIS
I'm joking right now I know I know do my
dad and the other dads were just sitting
in his Jeep and just like follow us you
know by like a block just drinking beers
just sit in the car and be like hi you
guys go and they were just slamming six
there's a Michelob all night that's
pretty good
yeah that's and I was I remember as it
can be like I want to be that dad I want
to be like just like drinking driving
hanging out with the boys you know what
they take a Vig out of your Reese's Cups
when you got in the car [ __ ] yeah they
would they would their beak yeah take a
skim all right you got one Foley I got
one I ever have sherbert as a family
growing up with sure bra an option
big sherbert family and we'd all eat out
of the carton with everyone had their
own spoon what that thing went in ten
seconds did you guys drink out of the
milk carton - was that a thing my dad
did he called it a midnight snack it was
4 p.m. your dad plays it fast and loose
and I gonna like it Tony you're telling
me as dessert your mom would throw a
container of sherbert on the table you
each have a spoon and just go at it yeah
Briar's - and also it had that icy [ __ ]
at the top to get the scoop that off
yeah there is something kind of like
nice and impulsive about a family all
you know sharing one table with sherbert
though like savages what are you talking
to my family would never do like Abner
we're not in that close but that's at
least shows a level of closeness you
know where there you go it's pretty good
I know but seen your dad in a robe with
no underwear even sure but out of a
carton
that's a rough visual that is a tough
look man yikes
oh man [ __ ] you know what I did a
garbage day this week I ran out of
shampoo so it's like we're on like I had
a like add water to like get some extra
legs out of it oh sure he won but you
forget about it for a couple of days -
cuz you only think
about the [ __ ] you need in the shower
when you're in the shower you know right
that's up there with a cut in the
toothpaste tube I've never done that
that's you get the you get a little
swirl and the toothbrush in there yeah
we had a little roller that fit on the
end of the toothpaste and we had the
[ __ ] crank every [ __ ] drop out
before my mom would go to the store and
get another one and they were this is
when they were metal when that's when
the toothpaste containers were made of
metal oh those things you feel like a
[ __ ] iron worker charge when it got
to the end of it like a tin knocker yeah
Wow doctor that's a good name for a gay
[Laughter]
yeah yeah me too I think you I mean a
lot of these I think you're you know the
zero fun kind of answered you know in
the household yeah different different
colored ketchup ever uh like purple
ketchup and green ketchup he's not yeah
what do you mean the [ __ ] disk or
pians are killing the dog in the
backyard yeah Jumanji on that house yeah
that was up there with the hamburger
phone and and board games was your mom
was your mom a good cook you think she
is but she wasn't she was pretty rough
and it was it was a bummer we've lied to
her since today what was a typical
dinner like what would you guys all sit
down and have dinner together most times
growing up yeah it was a lot of
whatever's in the fridge like it was
like alright we got a half a chicken
carcass
we got zucchini and we got pasta sauce
so something like that Wow
what about milk with dinner was that a
thing when you were a kid we did you
have milk with dinner or was that girl
we had we had powdered milk
oh really yeah my dad used to use orange
juice for the cereal cuz he's gonna use
the milk this is insane
dude I love it oh man alright were you a
big league chew or a bubble tape kind of
guy oh I wanted to be a big league chew
guy but I was really more of a bubble
tape for you not Sam yeah I wanted dude
I wanted to be a big I wanted to have
big league chew confidence I
just never really could pull it off and
like whenever you open up the bag you
wanted people to see you you know I
wanted people to be like is that kid
chewing tobacco over there you know you
like packing a big hook in there oh no I
was a feeling I was a big league chew
guy and we used to look at bubble tape
kids as like the Kennedys kids like a
bubble tape that was because you had the
cuz you had a little container that you
could like put [ __ ] in it later on
you always have two container big like
chu was [ __ ] gar we lookin we're
eatin [ __ ] chewing tobacco what parent
in their right mind would say yeah here
go for this that's how I felt about
Lunchables I mean I'm in the school
cafeteria with a garbage bag and Ja sure
I can imagine what you got sent with to
give me a jar for chocolate milk and I
had to bring the jar home so I'm walking
around all I ever used to refuse to take
a prop my mom would try to send me with
like the insulated lunch bag or the box
and I'm like nah paper I'm not bringing
this bag every day give me a paper bag
that I can toss it was oh sorry
no please go ahead the ultimate one was
you know the newspaper it would come in
that little slim bag oh my mom would use
that for lunch I'd have the Daily News
on my on my sourdough and plus they
could see in some time if it was a clear
bag they could see what you had like a
banana like it has orange slice or
whatever they they saw your wacky your
wacky lunch I know I the want ads on my
sandwich there's a little rod to the
garage sales for that week what would
the jar be that's what I wanted to ask
you I mean to cut you off what would the
jar be was it would that be like a
mayonnaise jar yeah it was a manage I
was like a ball jar like a glassed you
are with the metal top holy [ __ ] I'm
what you put in that like super stuff no
as always chocolate milk chocolate milk
jeez it's like to kill a mockingbirds
man this is [ __ ] hardcore [ __ ] Oh
another basic one that I mean you grew
up like suburban ashour a big house did
you have a second fridge in the house
either a garage or basement that's
obscene living that's a good one and I
had a lot of friends with that but again
no food so
need for a second free cheese I'm not
gonna have an empty second fridge man I
do love a good second fridge you'd open
it up leave sometimes like that my
brother's place now but like you open it
up and there's just like it looks like
it's MTV Cribs it's just a glass of red
Gatorade purple Gator it's great that's
a big thing with the second fridge is
always higher scale of food it's always
like tostito [ __ ] pizza rolls and all
that [ __ ] yeah we talked about the
garage fridge all the time we're big
garage for its kids well did you have a
frozen pizza growing up like what you're
going even now like what's your go-to
frozen pizza back then it was Totino's
or whatever the hell that one is and and
one time I couldn't get the oven to work
so I heated it on a lamp but some of
these stories could be from prison he's
making hooch in that's in the toilet and
stuff Shawshank Norman over here oh wait
till I tell you about the things I
[ __ ] you know that's not under the dog
I got last question on my side did I did
you or any member of your family at any
time on the anti car theft detect a
defense system known as the club they
kind of had to at this point I get it
they should have put it on the front
door yeah we had a club and the high-end
people had a Viper
remember the Viper huh yeah it would be
pout you gonna like engaged or whatever
yes that was hot [ __ ] now those things
that did those things work I feel like
they didn't prevent anybody's car from
getting taken no I think it was for the
sticker you got this it was almost like
the end of the the thing on the front
lawn that tells you them and shield or
anything yeah yes someone's gonna break
in if they see the sticker right moving
yeah that's it that's great man
Kip you got anything else now that's it
let's leave on the club the club and the
Viper baby buddy hardcore look at you
now though buddy [ __ ] the West
Village apartment you're a [ __ ]
homeowner you're [ __ ] one of the
biggest comics out there [ __ ] killing
it uh I probably but anything's my
friend again it takes those beginning
to get to this sure this is still [ __ ]
so you know they would in the ends a
yeah
mark is there anything you want the gang
to know that they might not already know
coming up down the line anything other
than stories yeah Tuesday's with stories
my podcast with Joe list I think former
guest yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah he's
trash oh there was some things that list
was like hard no and then some things he
was just like it was like back up the
[ __ ] dumpster and throw him in I can
tell you some list day I don't know if
he got to personally as a pool table in
his living room no furniture furniture
just a pool table
that's tough that is the first thing you
see when you walk into his house is
somebody painted like script on his wall
like hey if you're gonna have a glass of
wine don't come wine in here without
some cheese or some [ __ ] like that some
trashy Irish proverb or something yes
anybody that has live laugh love
somewhere in their house that's [ __ ]
garbage garbage garbage but yeah listen
my plan I got a special on YouTube
coming out in May 12th and yeah check my
website markoma comedy calm for road
dates would we ever get back out of this
[ __ ] Corona jizz and yeah praise Allah
I hear some promising things that it's
hope but some clubs are opening up some
somebody was tweeting that like like my
agent hit me up there you know the clubs
are starting to kind of open the doors a
little bit I don't know good thank you
fries all right sorry sorry all right
well cut it up most guys make sure you
check out are you garbage anywhere you
guys get podcast to follow us on on
YouTube
brain review subscribe all that good
jazz you know yeah mark thank you so
much buddy we really appreciate you
coming and sitting down with us thank
you that was fun thanks for having me
toodles
say bye brother take care